deux événements autour de la prison de
bois d'arcy ces derniers jours et donc
l'importance d'en parler c'est tout
d'abord jeudi dernier une magistrate qui
a ordonné la remise en liberté d'un
détenu choqué par ces conditions de
détention ce détenu n'est toujours pas
libéré sera fixé sur son sort ce jeudi
et puis c'était aussi quelques jours
auparavant le 23 juin un détenu qui
s'est pendu dans sa cellule cédric
torrès bonsoir vous êtes de l'ufap unsa
justice est le premier syndicat
pénitentiaire
alors d'abord ceux détenus qui
pourraient être libérés à qu'en raison
de ses conditions de détention c'est une
première comment vous réagissez
c'est très surprenant on a en fait on
quand on a appris ça on était très très
très surpris mais tout le monde en fait
parce qu'effectivement il décrit des
problèmes de vétusté
l'étanchéité parce que ces pour
le fond du problème en fait et malgré
toutes les rénovations qu'on peut
entreprendre aujourd'hui on est dans une
phase un problème où il ya plus d'argent
dans les caisses de l'état donc pour
faire pour faire des travaux il faut de
l'argent et bien on essaye de faire du
bricolage aujourd'hui dans toute maison
à bois d'arcy mais partout ailleurs
donc en fait il
et j'en viens justement de vous parler
du mot vétusté est ce que les conditions
sont à ce point est difficile à la
prison de bois d'arcy en fait bizarre si
si vous voulez et elle a aujourd'hui 500
places théoriques
aujourd'hui on est à 800 détenus
incarcérés à boire si c'est à environ
165 70 % des surpopulation c'est la
maison d'arrêt la plus surpeuplée de
l'île de france parce que bon on peut
vous avez d'autres maisons d'arrêt qui
sont surpeuplés mais c'est vrai que nous
on est on est presque au bord pourra
presque plus prendre de monde et c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
qui dit surpopulation dit dégradation
plus importante et plus rapide
alors c'est étonnant comme ce que vous
dites parce que 800 détenus 500 places
la prison n'est pas un ancien à maison
d'arrêt de bois d'arcy elle date de 1981
mais ce n est pas très ancienne comment
vous expliquer cette dégradation des
conditions de vie à l'intérieur pour
l'impressionner alors elle a été
construite à la base parce que c'était
d'abord elle devait faire elle devait ça
devait être un centre de détention
c'est à dire en établissements pour
peine non membres et 6 et plaident pour
ce qui est des téléspectateurs via la
maison d'arrêt il ya les centres de
détention et d'aller centrale il y a
deux maisons d'arrêt de versailles
celle de bois d'arcy une maison il ya
une maison sans trac est à poisy
centrale en gros pour résumer celle de
très longues peines oui c'est les
adresses et les prévenus et détenus de
courtes peines ouais c'est ça la
question des tensions entre les centres
de détention vous avez des six que des
condamnés à des peines importantes qui
restent mais la vraie c'est vraiment des
établissements pour peine comme les
centrales centrale c'est plus
sécuritaire centre des tensions cgtv un
petit peu plus coulante l ensemble des
tensions et dans les centrales c'est un
prisonniers par cellule ou dans les
maisons d'arrêt
trois aujourd'hui bonheur si vous avez
des cellules à 3 ne fait quand même pour
trois détenus donc c'est un dogme c'est
ingérable
je disais intolérable c'est le mot mais
c'est gérable aussi parce que cette
surveillance depuis six ans comment on
vit le quotidien quand on a affaire
comme ça des détenus qui sont en
surpopulation donc forcément on imagine
beaucoup plus nerveux quand il faut
faire c'est super attention il faut
faire très attention à soi faut faire
très attention à ce qu'on fait et ce que
l'on dit après on peut comprendre aussi
que les détenus qui sont trois dans une
même cellule
la moine la moindre chose qui va pas ça
va d'ici de prendre des proportions
énormes
là on parle présente des articles parce
qu'il ya cette décision d'un magistrat
c'est une première malgré tout en 2010
et déjà eu un rapport de jean marie
delarue qui était contrôleur général des
lieux de privation de liberté et qui
avait déjà dénoncé de nombreux
dysfonctionnements l'établissement ils
évoquaient effectivement ces fameuses
cellules de 10 mètres carrés équipée de
trois lits il parlait aussi d'un espace
wc très restreint de seulement de l'eau
froide qui arrivent dans les lavabos et
il disait c'est les conditions de vie ne
sont pas dignes et ne devrait pas
perdurer alors en mai dernier
donc trois ans après ce rapport de jean
marie delarue la christiane taubira la
garde des sceaux a répondu en disant
qu'un schéma directeur de rénovation est
à l'étude pour bois d'arcy
qu'en est il c'est vrai qu'il ya eu il y
avait un plan il ya un plan de
rénovation qui préjugent pour la maison
d'arrêt de bois d'arcy mais aujourd'hui
c'est pareil si tout ça ça coûte ça
coûte de l'argent
maintenant il faut savoir aussi qu'on a
eue il ya eu l'administration
pénitentiaire a dû faire face à une
rénovation importante de fleury mérogis
et dernièrement donné des baumettes donc
peut-être que tous les crédits sont
partis crédit combat des refoulés ça on
a pas on a juste des travaux qui a qui
sont en cours mais sur le précieux des
travaux en cours
mais est ce que demain au moral et de
chants cellule de l'eau chaude
tu crois pas ça risque de prendre du
temps c'est du bricolage sûr on a du
personnel aujourd'hui technique du
personnel sur de surveillance qui font
leur travail avec ce qu'ils peuvent et
avec le manque d'argent flagrant etc
mais c'est grave ça devient très très
grave parce que lyon met en péril la
sécurité du personnel que ce soit
technique ou même s'était surveillance
mais et puis pour les détenus 9 mètres
carrés
dehors c'est pas acceptable détention
salengro - aujourd'hui ça l'est pas
avant de continuer cet entretien que
vous parlez peut-être plus longuement
ses de vos conditions de travail vous
propose de regarder cette question du
jour tous les jours on va poser une
question aux habitants de la rue alors
que pensez vous justement la libération
d'un prisonnier pour mauvaises
conditions de détention
c'est un micro trottoir qui a justement
été réalisé à bois d'arcy en gros les
gens répondent oui pour la prison mais
dans les conditions dignes et on écoute
ce que croit toutefois pas libérer les
gens parce que les conditions sur une
acceptable il faut soit rénové sa
transférer les gens enfin bon les
suivants si c'est à ces agrumes in hell
ou si c'est un vol ou quelque chose
comme ça
quelque chose de grave autres membres
moi je serais d'accord de au moins de
lui faire quelque chose de plus le plus
convenable
je lui offrirai des conditions des
conditions de détention normale puisque
un peu la justice a tranché il la
justice qui se rendre en prison
folies tour vous trouverez un moyen pour
qu'ils puissent dormir dans un lit
autrement dit vertical
c'est très compliqué à mon avis parce
que c'est vrai que les humains devraient
être considérés entre man même en prison
mais de leurs hottes de le remettre en
liberté c'est peut-être aussi dangereux
pour la société
je suis pas non plus pour des supers
conditions de tension la prison à cette
prison mais il ya sûrement des limites
quoi le cas de bonheur c'est parce qu'on
vend par ce soir mais c'est pas un cas
isolé ne faut pas stigmatiser sur cette
maison d'arrêt en mai dernier
l'administration pénitentiaire
communiqué ces chiffres qui sont
éloquents il ya soixante sept mille huit
cent trente neuf personnes incarcérées
en france et c'est un chiffre record en
2013 surtout quand on sait que la
capacité d'accueil des prisons est de 57
un peu plus de 57 milles places donc 50
57 mille places pour soixante sept mille
personnes incarcérées
la surpopulation ça ne concerne pas que
que bois d'arcy qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire votre avis qu'il faudrait aménager
des peines mais trop de gens en prison
par exemple si vous avez des des peines
de petites peines parce que l'ufap unsa
justice se bat depuis très longtemps et
demande ce qu effectivement une des
aménagements de peine le bracelet
électronique des travaux d'intérêts
généraux de enfin qui est plein de
mesures qui peuvent être accompagnés et
qui peuvent éviter la détention à des
petites peines et qui seront plus
éducatif que la détention elle même
effectivement parler de courtes peines
pour les maisons d'arrêt ça peut être
quoi une courte peine vous pouvez avoir
on a déjà vu des gens incarcérés pour le
week end d'accord c'est il rentre le en
bourse aux jouets dans les cellules à
les voir enfin ils sont là ils restent
au quartier arrivants donc c'est encore
différent qui sont en général que deux
il passe sa vie dans ces fameuses
cellules de 10 mètres carrés à trois et
on peut retrouver des gens qui sont là
pour purger peut-être de moi ou trois
mois de prison
les gens comparent fait des délits non
plus sur les délits certes mais pas vous
avez
mais effectivement c'est pas des pnc par
du vol du ou de la dette à la personne
c'est pas des choses qui passent en
criminel ou que ça va passer aux assises
ou peut-être en correctionnelle mais
cessera pas de du criminel quand donc
effectivement vous avez des peines ses
petites peines l'a1 peut-être que sur
tous ces détenus qui sont très jeunes
qui ont eu 18 entre 18 et 25 ans qui ont
des petites peines de ce type donc ces
gens là
peut-être que accompagner une mesure par
deux brasses électronique ou de travaux
d'intérêts généraux qui seront peut-être
plus éducative de forme éducatif qui
éviteront la récidive et le retour en
prison surtout parce que c'est vrai que
c'est eux qui nous encombre un peu
d'offrir 6 en surveillant la prison de
bois d'arcy malgré tout le matin quand
vous vous levez vous y aller se rincer
on va bosser qu'elle faisait elle est
serein well de la rencontre oui non non
non jamais jamais parce que si j'ai la
boule au ventre je fais demi tour je
veux changer métiers dont celui non
c'est comme ça merci en tout cas à cyril
torres d'être venu apporter votre
témoignage et plus votre éclairage sur
cette maison d'arrêt de bois d'arcy